[Music]
won't have the same problems that ended
our world on earth
go now
start over initiating trimester one
these children are the future of
[Music]
humanity
[Music]
you will raise these children
to be atheists was belief in the unreal
that destroyed the earth
our enemies built an arc which is now
headed here
the only known planet where humans can
survive and should the mythrakes arc
ever make it here
you will not listen to their words they
believe that allowing androids to raise
human children
is a sin
we must rescue our stolen children
do not tell them what i am
i want to talk to you without the
android for a second
she's not a nerd
she's holding him captive he needs to be
with other humans
i thought we were in sync father we've
increasingly taken to
impulses
how many people did you kill on earth
mother you are all my children
i'm only here to protect you
she's the most powerful weapon on this
planet
i gotta destroy her
what do you want
i want my children to be safe
[Music]
[Music]
gather round children
[Music]
the earth was destroyed
i was programmed to protect you
does anyone know the story of the three
little pigs the first little pig
built a house out of straw the second
little paper
built a house out of sticks but the
third little pig
he built a house out of stone
one day
a big bad wolf came along
and said little pig little pig let me in
or i'll huff
and i'll blow your house
a big bad wolf she was talking about
mother
that's her
good
you